oui bon je mets salés un juste au cas où
pour vous prévenir que cet épisode
utilise des extraits issus de films
d'horreur qui peuvent choquer les plus
jeunes
mais après c'est cool hein vous pouvez
rester bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va
faire dans le sensationnel on va parler
de chair de sang du bruit des os qui
craquent et des derniers sursaut
agonisant de l'humanité décrit pitt qui
tente vainement de survivre dans un
monde violent et post apocalyptique
après la chute d'un mode occidentale qui
s'est écroulé sous ses propres
contradictions et là on va parler de
donald trump
ça aurait pu mais non on va parler de
zombies
à la belle allée howey ça marche aussi
alors je précise que contrairement aux
autres vidéos où j'avais un thème et un
questionnement bien précis l'objectif
ici ça va plutôt être de s'interroger
sur ce que la figure du zombie
représente aujourd'hui quelles sont ses
origines
qu'est ce qu'il dit de notre société et
on va dégager plusieurs pistes
d'exploration que l'on voit se profiler
au fil des films de zombies alors ça
fait un moment que je travaille sur
cette vidéo et genre combien de temps
genre longtemps spot reçu un oui mais
qui tétouan en fait en moi je ne suis
qu'un produit de son imagination qui te
permet dont on a fini solitude de penser
que tu t'adresses effectivement à
quelqu'un on se retrouverait pas un peu
il se trouve que le grand george romero
lui même considéré à raison comme le
créateur des zombies a rendu l'âme le 16
juillet dernier j'en profite donc pour
lui rendre un vibrant hommage à travers
cette vidéo merci georges meyer
insomnies je te les lois y aurait encore
ma gueule mais avant d'aller plus loin
est ce que tout le monde voit bien de
quoi on est en train de parler ici alors
pour les deux du fond qui aurait vécu
enfermés chez eux on s'écoute en pousser
les cheveux pendant ces quarante
dernières années
le zombie c'est seulement vivent bien
connue des films d'épouvanté qui avance
avec la velléité d'un lémurien sous
morphine pour dévorer des humains ou
seulement leur cerveau dans certaines
versions et qui sont quasiment
indestructible puisque la seule façon de
les tuer définitivement et de détruire
leur cerveau et à ce petit jeu toutes
les idées sont bonnes on peut se la joue
et original en utilisant les pales d'un
hélicoptère partir en mode violeau en
attaquant des zombies nazis à la
tronçonneuse ou encore faire preuve de
créativité avec un piano ou même en
banjo ou bien sûr une batte de base-ball
puisque après tout on est en amérique et
que tout le monde on a une qui traîne
quelque part dans ses affaires alors oui
le zombie est bien cette créature son
vie qui avance lentement mais
inexorablement vers l'anéantissement
total de l'humanité mais il n'est pas
que ça ce qu'on va voir c'est que la
figure du zombie a grandement évolué à
travers le temps si elle est
originellement une pratiques vaudou
et haïti elle s'est finalement imposée
dans les années soixante dix à travers
le cinéma américain et on la retrouve
aujourd'hui décliné à plein de médias
différents notamment les jeux vidéo dans
lequel ils ont un rôle assez
prépondérant
diantre en effet le zombie moderne
depuis ses origines dans l'univers
horrifique et un d'un gramme du cinéma
de genre ce mort vivant s'est
progressivement imposée un peu partout
jusqu'à devenir un schéma récurrent de
nos univers de référence
on l'a vu faire son apparition dans les
séries à succès et il a même pointé son
nez semblant de l'autre côté de notre
écran depuis la paupérisation des zombie
walk qui nous font voir tous les ans des
armée de morts-vivants prendre le
contrôle de nos villes lors de marches
sauvage sous le signe du partage et de
l'hémoglobine
il te ressemble un peu le dernier et non
non c'est le filet de sang ça fait
toujours ça mais en parlant de la zombie
walk justement quoi de mieux que cet
environnement à la fois glauque et
fascinante pour mener notre enquête sur
ce nouveau mythe contemporain
je vais donc profiter de la présence de
ce clown si pauvrement par bus pour
l'envoyer en reconnaissance et alors
saisissez vous de votre batte de
baseball ou de tout autre objet
contondant si vous n'avez pas la chance
de vivre dans un film américain
et puis on est parti
[Musique]
et bonjour à tous bienvenue à la zombie
walk de paris 2010 est où les zombies
prennent momentanément possession de
notre ville pour rassembler en hommage
au maître de l'horreur par titre au tour
rejoindre ses créatures il est alors
tombé dans paris 10 oct notons qu'en
revient la nuit qu il ya des zones
humides a reparu rien n'est plus pareil
quand il en sera fini on peut les voir
sur le combat va oui mais vraiment
son disque eux
les trottoirs
bonjour rire et comme vous pouvez le
constater les zombies possède de
nombreux fans et tout le monde ne serait
ce pas forcément à la même version du
zombie mais la plupart des gens
s'accordent quand même vous placez
l'origine des zombies avec la nuit des
morts vivants de george romero soit
sorti en 1968
la particularité du zombie dans la
culture populaire c'est donc que c'est
une figure très récente
contrairement aux vampires loups garous
qui existe depuis plusieurs centaines
d'années les zombies en fête existe
depuis 50 ans à tout casser
ce qui fait donc une figure très
récentes d'autres imaginaires
[Musique]
vous
ça en fait donc une figure très jeune
pour un mythe aussi répandu mais est-ce
que les zombies n'existait vraiment pas
avant 1960 alors faisons un peu
d'histoire bas
[Musique]
on peut voir une sorte de précurseur aux
zombies dans le roman de mary shelley
frankenstein ou le prométhée moderne qui
paraît en 1818
la créature de frankenstein n'est pas
réellement un zombie puisqu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un mort revenue à la vie mais d'un
être composé de chair morte dans lequel
on arrive à insuffler la vie
symboliquement cependant on retrouve
déjà avec frankenstein les thèmes forts
qui baliseront la figure du zombie
l'oeuvre puise ses sources dans une
période historique tourmenté l'époque de
mary shelley celle de la seconde
génération romantique où les
intellectuels sont portés par un désir
d'émancipation mais sont également
horrifié fasciné par les violences de la
révolution le contexte est également
celui de la révolution industrielle
cette fois qu'ils voient l'abandon des
sociétés rurales pour des populations
citadines avec la naissance des grandes
usines et de l'exploitation des zones
par le travail le sous titre est
également significatif le nouveau
prométhée fait référence au mythe de
prométhée qui donna le feu aux hommes
symbole de la connaissance
frankenstein représente donc cette part
de mauvais qu'il peut y avoir dans le
progrès de la science et de la technique
qui peut nous amener à créer une
créature horrible et incontrôlable qui
finira par se retourner contre son
créateur
on a donc une société moderne qui au nom
du progrès scientifique créé elle même
l'objet de sa destruction
on a également le thème du dégoût pour
la chair en décomposition que le n'ose
pas regarder en face et finalement le
thème de la révolte que la créature sur
son créateur c'est en germe la plupart
des thèmes forts que l'on retrouvera
développer dans le cinéma de zombies
mais revenons aux zombies justement dans
bull le zombie tire ses origines d'un
mythe haïtien c'est une pratique vaudou
vie constitue et à faire boire une
substance je loue un individu de façon à
stopper ses fonctions vitales à
l'enterrer pendant 24 heures et à le
faire réémerger privé de son libre
arbitre
cette version du zombie est très liée à
l'esclavagé et c'est sous cette forme
que les zombies font leur toute première
apparition au cinéma dans le film white
zombie de victor halpérin sortie en 1932
avec bela lugosi dans le rôle de
l'enfant termiste hic les zombies ne
sont pas encore les morts en
putréfaction que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ce sont des corps ramenés à
la vie et réduit en esclavage et ils
sont très liés à leurs maîtres qui les
contrôle grâce à un mental
malgré un film dans les années 40 le
thème des zombies ne sera pas beaucoup
utilisé au cinéma jusqu'à sa
redécouverte et sa réutilisation par
george romero dans la nuit des morts
vivants
on arrive maintenant véritablement à
l'acte de naissance du zombie moderne
avec ce qui est maintenant conçus comme
la tétralogie romero avec la nuit des
morts-vivants en 1968 le crépuscule des
morts vivants en 1978 le jour des morts
vivants en 1985 et le territoire des
morts vivants en 2005 mais tout à fait
jaloux ou plutôt devrais-je dire claude
deux mois mais n'a qui se donnent la
réplique de façon fort pratique parce
que c'est vrai que les films de zombies
ont bien été déclinée sous toutes les
formes de franchise un allant du
blockbuster à la série z et comme je
veux pas parler tout on va passer un
petit moment avec ces quatre là parce
qu'avec la tétralogie romero on voit
vraiment l'évolution du genre et la mise
en place de tout ce qui fait la
particularité du zombie à la fois dans
sa façon particulière d'envisager le
cinéma d'horreur mais aussi dans sa
dimension critique de la société
plongeons-nous donc dans l'univers des
zombies tels que nous les dépeint george
romero
dans cette version le zombie est bien un
mort vivant ils avancent lentement les
bras en avant ils bavent du sang et il
est extrêmement violent et agressif
malgré son extrême lenteur alors je
crois qu'on vient de passer un nouveau
palier sur l'échelle de la crédibilité
tu ne remet un coup encore une fois
allez une dernière pour la route
bon trêve de billevesées enchaîné mais
ce qui fait sans doute la particularité
du zombie c'est son ombre effectivement
on ne dit pratiquement jamais un zombie
au singulier
on parle toujours de zombies au pluriel
puisque le zombie est en masse
d'ailleurs un zombie tout seul est
rarement une menace c'est leur nombre
qui font qu'ils sont particulièrement
dangereux
c'est en ça que les zombies sont
réellement une métaphore de la société
tout entière et de l'insidieuse menace
qu'elle représente
peu importe qu'elles avancent lentement
elle finira toujours par nous rattraper
et par nous digérer c'est donc ça que
représente le zombie le zombie c'est
l'uniformisation sociale
[Musique]
alors pour bien comprendre ce que le
zombie a de particulier il est
intéressant de le comparer à un autre
mort vivant le vent qui comme on a vu le
zombie est finalement une figure assez
récente de notre imaginaire et il
appartient à une culture pop voire pulp
un peu underground le vampire quant à
lui existe un autre imaginaire depuis de
nombreuses années et il a déjà acquis
ses lettres de noblesse notamment en
littérature dans le dracula de bram
stocker mais la principale différence
entre les deux figures tient en ce que
le vampire est profondément élitiste
alors que le zombie lui est vulgaire
dans toutes les acceptions de ce mot
peut avoir mais en quoi le vampire est
il élitiste me demanderez-vous
c'est assez facile à vérifier quand on
regarde l'iconographie du vampire %
reine-elizabeth bigben tour de londres
tamise buckingham
or je suis prêt et je concède que ce
n'est peut-être pas le cas pour les
toutes premières apparitions du vampire
au cinéma le nosferatu de 1922 et
particulièrement hideux et ressemble
finalement assez à ce que sont devenus
les zombies d'aujourd'hui mais par la
suite le vampire a gagné en classe et en
élégance
il devient le comte dracula sous les
traits du regretté christopher lee et
s'il n'est pas encore ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de sexy il est déjà de la
haute société il fait montre d'une
classe indéniable avec son costume et sa
grande cape et par la suite les vampires
n'ont cessé d'aller vers le beau élégant
jusqu'au vampires modernes qui ont des
gueules de petits minets de classes
supérieures et qui vivent dans des
palaces ça donne envie
de façon générale le vampire va devenir
de plus en plus sexy et attirant à titre
d'exemple dans le fameux interview with
the vampire on n'a rien de moins que
brad pitt et tom cruise pour représenter
le degré de sexy tude que les vampires
doivent désormais dégagée je sais pas ce
qu'il vous faut
et plus généralement l'élitisme du
vampire se voit dans le simple fait que
son statut lui permet d'être immortel
tout en continuant à vivre
s'il a des proies sur lesquels il se
nourrit et préférentiellement des jeunes
filles vierges parce que le vampire a du
goût seules quelques-unes auront
l'honneur d'accéder à la transformation
réservé aux seuls happy few qui peuvent
s'en montrer digne
à ce titre l'histoire tout entière de
twilight c'est en fait celle d'une jeune
fille séduite par un membre de l'élite
immortel qui veut accéder au même statut
et il faudra pas moins de quatre films
pour qu'ils accèdent enfin sa requête
qu'est ce que tu écoutes c'est du début
si la figure élitiste du vampire n'a
jamais été aussi bien montrer ce
laonnois que dans l'excellent film de
jim jarmusch o'neal over the left live
qui soit dit en passant a été présenté
au festival de cannes
on n'imaginerait pas voir un film de
zombies adoubé d'une telle
reconnaissance institutionnelle
dans ce film les zombies sont des
artistes incompris ayant toujours côtoyé
les hautes sphères intellectuelles
ils sont entrés de façon sûre esthétisé
et leur élitisme se retrouvent même dans
leur façon de manger le sang des humains
est devenue impropre à la consommation
ils doivent se procurer du sens le plus
pur possible pour pouvoir survivre
c'est la version hipster du mort vivant
par excellence on est au 21ème siècle
bon sens j'avais pas l'attention il
était si mignon et maintenant je me sens
malade mais c'est pas étonnant bordel
il est dans l'industrie musicale ça
lâche moi al'inverse le zombie ne fait
pas tant de chichis et c'est en ça que
leurs figures sont diamétralement
opposées un sketch de norman sur le
sujet illustre très bien ce que je veux
montrer bon je vois ça j'ai arrêté
aujourd'hui je mange que des humains
issus de l'agriculture biologique
en plein air à stresser lui avec respect
tu manges encore de la viande toi tu
étais pas vg haoues ici carrément ouais
j'ai eu hier c'était mon dernier
ce sketch et de vol justement parce
qu'il représente tout ce que le zombie
n'est pas le zombie n'est pas élitiste
beau et manipulateur au contraire il est
sales puants en décomposition et premier
degré il ne fait pas le tri dans ses
victimes
ils mangent n'importe qui quel que soit
son âge sa taille son poids et sa classe
sociale contrairement aux vampires qui
est classe le zombie est grotesque il ne
crée pas de la différence mais de
l'uniformité
tout le monde peut potentiellement se
transformer en zombies et on aborde
notamment un point qui fait du film de
zombies une particularité
là où les personnages des films
d'horreur ont d'habitude peur de la mort
ou peur de souffrir les personnages de
films de zombies ont avant tout peur de
se transformer en zombie parce que loin
d'être une élévation vers l'immortalité
comme c'est le cas pour les vampires
cette transformation et dq comme une
déchéance
pourquoi est-ce une plus grande défiance
que la mort elle-même qu'est ce qui
paraît si horrible à l'idée de se
transformer en zombie c'est les
questions qu'on va essayer de se poser
en montrant que ce que représente le
zombie en fait c'est ce que j'appelle
linverse du processus de civilisation et
c'est là qu'on va commencer à parler
réellement de sociologie
[Musique]
alors la civilisation c'est un bien
grand mot mais on va devoir s'y attarder
un petit peu parce que c'est
essentiellement de ça que nous parle des
films de zombies en effet il montre
comment une société occidentale et plus
particulièrement la société américaine
avancé technologiquement et qui se pense
comme le phare démocratiques du monde
civilisé peut s'effondrer sous ses
propres contradictions on laissant place
à une barbarie et une violence son nom
et cette violence est d'autant plus
présente et viscérale du fait de la
corporéité des zombies et de leur
rapport à la nourriture parce que en
plus d'être anthropophage on peut noter
qu'ils ont une façon de manger plutôt
sage
bon je vais arrêter là les réjouissances
pardon pour les âmes sensibles
mais c'est important de passer par là
parce que c'est ce qui va nous permettre
de parler un petit peu de sociologie
alors ici je vais vous parler d'un des
grands noms de la chaussure logis
s'appelle norbert elias
il est allemand il est né en 1897 et il
est mort en 1990 donc autant dire que il
en a vu des choses
il publie sa thèse en 1939 dans le sujet
et ce qu'il appelle le processus de
civilisation il fait un travail de
longue haleine où il étudie la mise en
place des pouvoirs politiques récents en
occident c'est à dire la centralisation
des états-nations qu'il met justement en
relation avec ce fameux processus de
civilisation qu'on voit ici concrètement
comprendre comme un mécanisme
d'intériorisation de nos pulsions
animales
tu es encore fait un cauchemar c'est un
jedi ne fait pas de cauchemars
alors pour montrer sa il étudie en
particulier la société de cour qui se
met en place à versailles au xviie
siècle sous l'impulsion de louis xiv et
qui servira de modèle à la plupart des
cours européennes
si on a souvent l'impression que la
centralisation de l'état est l'oeuvre de
la révolution française c'est en fait un
processus qui commence bien avant et qui
prend ses racines dans la société de
cour de louis xiv et pour centraliser
davantage les pouvoirs l'état va donc
devoir acquérir le contrôle de la
violence physique
alors on aborde ici le thème de la
violence légitime qui a longuement été
étudiés par max weber
c'est un gros morceau et on pourrait
facilement y consacrer une vidéo entière
on trouve déjà l'idée dans le léviathan
de hobbes et elle se développe jusque
dans les penseurs contemporains au
premier rang desquels michel foucault et
sa longue réflexion sur le contrôle
social pour aller vite on peut
simplement dire que c'est dorénavant
l'état qui est le seul à avoir le droit
d'utiliser la violence et ce dans
quelques espaces que ce soit est-ce que
vous avez déjà tué non parce que
maintenant c'est que quand on tue il
faut demander pardon à dieu
par contre j'ai vendu des armes qui ont
servi à tuer ça compte ça je sais pas
froid que je demande alors c'est vrai
que pour nous contemporain ça nous
semble plus ou moins évident on est
habitué depuis tout petit au fait que si
on n'est pas d'accord avec son voisin la
solution c'est pas de lui taper dessus à
coups de pelle mais au moyen-âge ce
n'était pas si évident il va falloir
apprendre aux gens ne plus faire usage
de la violence ou du moins à le limiter
louis xiv commence donc cet
apprentissage au sein même de sa cour ou
petit à petit ce qui est mis en valeur
ce n'est plus du tout la force physique
le courage ou la bile été au combat mais
la maîtrise des vers l'adoption dans
langage raffiné et le contrôle de ses
pulsions votre cher amour
madame de pompadour sous sa belle
toilette queen cantons là pour
cette volonté de bannir la violence
physique avait déjà été affirmé lorsque
louis xiii interdit complètement les
duels judiciaire qui existaient bel et
bien le dernier duel judiciaire
autorisés ayant eu lieu en 1547 de
mangue crâne
et si les duels existe toujours après
cette date ils prennent la forme des
duels pour l'honneur dont l'imagerie
nous est souvent plus familière
aujourd'hui au passage louis xiv sont
crades abolir purement et simplement les
duels mais sans réel succès puisque même
si leur nombre se réduit
considérablement
ils persisteront assez tardivement le
dernier duel officielle en france datant
de 1967
oui oui 1967 a tout de suite là ça fait
assez anachronique et ridicule mais je
diverge et c'est beaucoup alors
reprenons le fil de notre pacification
des moeurs
au delà de la violence physique pure et
frontale c'est la totalité de notre
rapport à la vie qui va être modifiée
par cette avancée de la civilisation
c'est à dire les manières de se tenir à
table de se moucher de déféquer et même
la sexualité évoluent très rapidement
vers un refoulement de leur aspect
animal et pulsionnelle elias étudient
notamment les ouvrages de civilité qui
fleurissaient la renaissance et qui
constituent des espèces de manuel de
savoir vivre à l'usagé de la classe
dominante c'est là qu'on voit par
exemple que le crachat auparavant
considéré comme une pratique saine est
désormais perçue comme inconvenant et
dangereux parce qu'il favorise les
contagions la nudité reculer la
sexualité acquiert une dimension tabou
on ne doit plus en parler devant les
enfants
cette évolution des pratiques
s'accompagne également d'une évolution
de notre sensibilité comme le montrent
les sentiments de honte ou de dégoût que
nous éprouvons désormais pour des
pratiques non civilisés mais qui au
moyen-âge était parfaitement banal et en
parlant de pratique banale qui ont
changé elia se passe un assez long
moment à développer le moment où les
couverts se sont imposé comme la seule
façon civilisée de manger de façon que
l'on n'utilise plus du tout nos doigts
pour manger aujourd'hui alors je te vois
venir avec ton commentaire je rappelle
qu'on parle de l'occident et il montre
que l'utilisation d'une fourchette ou
d'une cuillère et prototypique de ce
processus de civilisation qui vise à
mettre à distance tout ce qui pourrait
se rapprocher de l'animalité ou de la
pulsion j'ai tiré que votre amie ne veut
pas se mettre à table c'est gênant mais
point nos vieux n'a pas de manière pour
manger y est il est déjà heureux
le reste vient mon fidèle à première si
seigneurie les crashs d'applaudir sous
le tapis c'est dégueulasse ça suffit
mais à table avec nous à alger ce n'est
un bon ça couilles tu ne veux pas venir
à stable avec nous non non je n'irai pas
chez moi tout le monde dont cet homme
allez venez ça me coupe la bêtise et
cette signification du couvert pour
représenter la civilisation est toujours
bien actuelle puisque c'est bien souvent
par son utilisation que l'on va marquer
la différence entre les sociétés
humaines et animales
on le voit dans le film l'enfant sauvage
de françois truffaut qui raconte
l'histoire vraie de la difficile
acclimatation à la société de victor de
l'aveyron un enfant ayant vécu dans la
forêt jusqu'à environ ses 8 ans et on
peut voir exactement le même symbolisme
dans les différentes adaptations de
l'histoire de tarzan l'horreur
et on voit donc qu'on considère
globalement comme sauvage barbare ou
incivilisés toute personne qui ne sait
pas utiliser proprement découvert plus
que simplement utiles ces petites choses
représente donc à elle seule un rapport
entier au monde qui prend place dans une
société bien particulière au york hall à
sanaa je ne vais pas multiplier les
exemples et nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler de tarzan dans un prochain
épisode c'est à dire dans quatre ans il
me base sur le rythme actuel
elias montre donc que le processus de
civilisation est toujours en cours
aujourd'hui et il étudie comment les
normes dont ceux diffusés depuis la cour
du roi jusque dans le reste de la
population ce qu'il veut montrer c'est
que l'homme actuelles mesurées qui
contrôle ses pulsions et qui ne fracasse
pas ses congénères à coups de pelle au
premier problème se construit en fait
depuis 400 ans d'intériorisation des
pulsions docteur banner sa part être le
bon moment vous mettre en colère
et voilà mon secret qui a fait
je n'ai jamais cessé d'être en colère
bon après le mec a pas trop de chance
non plus il est juif
il est allemand et il publie une thèse
sur le processus de civilisation en 1939
donc autant dire que ça fait pas super
et qu à ce moment là dans la population
scientifique alors comme ça on vit dans
une époque de moins en moins violente
comme c'est intéressant mais bon ces
écrits seront re découvert par la suite
notamment publié en français dans les
années 70 et il ya quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de bonnes choses dedans ce qui
est intéressant de voir c'est que à
l'échelle de la civilisation occidentale
le processus a été long à se diffuser
continue encore aujourd'hui à s'affiner
mais à l'échelle d'une seule personne
par contre tout ce processus qui met
normalement 400 ans est beaucoup plus
rapide puisque il faut l'intégrer en une
vingtaine d'années ne fait un individu
moderne s'il veut être intégrés à la
société être considéré comme un individu
normal
il doit prendre en accéléré tout ce
processus de civilisation qui s'est
opéré pendant ces quatre cent dernières
années
et de fait la période de l'enfance
s'allonge mécaniquement pas ce qu'il ya
de plus en plus de normes intégré de
règles à respecter et de pulsions à
réfréner au fur et à mesure qu'on avance
dans ce processus de civilisation et sa
thèse c'est donc confirmer parce qu'on
vit aujourd'hui dans la société la moins
violente qui ait jamais existé
je sais que vous en avez peut-être pas
l'impression parce que si on fait
attention aux médias et à tout ce qu'on
entend autour de nous on peut avoir
l'impression qu'on vit dans une société
de plus en plus violente
mais en fait si on regarde ce que nous
dit la science à ce sujet c'est plutôt
notre sensibilité à la violence que la
violence réelle qui s'est accrue et en
fait on vit vraiment aujourd'hui dont
deux sociétés moins violentes
si ça vous intéresse je vous conseille
d'aller voir ce que dit laurent
mucchielli qui est spécialiste de la
question et qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle l'invention de la violence
globalement il ya toujours des petites
variations de notes de configurer lie à
tel ou tel événement vous tendance dans
la société mais globalement que l'on
remonte et puis on s'aperçoit que la
société d'autrefois étaient beaucoup
plus violente que celle d'aujourd'hui
mais alors pourquoi je vous parle de
tout ça au milieu d'une vidéo sur les
zombies
même si je pense que la plupart d'entre
vous ont déjà vu où je veux en venir
il est assez clair que les zombies
n'utilise pas de fourchette pour aller
plus loin on peut même dire que le
zombie ne connaît aucune norme aucune
règle aucun refoulement au contraire il
n'est que pulsions et cette pulsion est
elle même tellement forte qu'elle lui
permet de dépasser les lois de la
biologie et de continuer à bouger quand
ils devraient être mort depuis bien
longtemps
c'est notamment ceux qui étudient le
scientifique du troisième film quand il
s'aperçoit que les zombies fonctionne
avant tout à l'instinct si je comprends
ce qu'ils demandent l'arrêt qu'il
voudrait danger et pourtant il n'a plus
l'estomac
ils ne diront plus de substance de ce
qu'il ingère il ne marche qu'à l'instar
pourrait bien supprimée mais du coup
quel serait le message ici comme je les
ai déjà fait remarquer ce n'est pas
anodin que les zombies arrive
précisément au milieu de la société
occidentale et plus particulièrement aux
états unis où la cud eburnie protestante
et l'hygiénisme à outrance a conduit
l'intériorisation des pulsions à un
degré encore inédit jusque là et de fait
on est en droit de se demander si le
refoulement de nos pulsions animales qui
est aujourd'hui un préalable à la vie
dans nos sociétés humaines est
nécessairement une chose souhaitable ou
si elle ne génère pas elle même les
pétages de plomb qui en résulte j'essaie
tous tués tous
ce sentiment qu'ils aient causé comme
des animaux je les hais la colère et un
sentiment humain je suis jedi je sais
que je vaux mieux que ça
la psychanalyse d'ailleurs une nouvelle
forme de médecine qui apparaît au dix
neuvième siècle précisément parce que le
refoulement à outrance notre animalité
semble causer divers trous le manteau et
les états unis font régulièrement la
douloureuse expérience de ce qui arrive
quand la dose de refoulement demandé par
une société aseptisée est trop forte et
que les individus pète littéralement une
durite et à ce titre les zombies peuvent
donc se comprendre littéralement comme
ce pétage de plomb de la civilisation
en voulant trop refouler ses passions
contenir nos pulsions et aseptisée nos
environnements on en oublie que nous
sommes avant tout des animaux fait de
chair et les zombies représente
justement cette animalité primales et
bestial qui sommeille en chacun de nous
une montagne de refoulement pulsionnel
mais pour bien comprendre le film de
zombies il faut maintenant le replacer
dans le contexte qui l'a vu naître c'est
à dire 1968 et l'émergence d'une contre
culture
[Musique]